On September 16, 2022,
a young woman died in an Iranian hospital.
Her friends knew her as Masha. She
was at home for her family. She was Gina.
This was the name her mother
called out when she cried at her grave.
Gina is a beautiful Kurdish name it
means life
massagina  Amini was just 21 years old
when she was killed by the Iranian moral police
two days earlier she had been arrested
because she showed too much hair
she was already beaten in the police car
she fell into a
coma gina never woke up again
but millions of her compatriots have  They stood
up in their place
and they continue to stand up, they
risk prison, exile or even
death, they stand up for women's life and
freedom
and that's why we are here in Potsdam this evening
to honor the life of Gina
and the countless Iranian women
and men  To honor those who risk their lives every day
for justice,
freedom and democracy.
We honor all the heroes
of Live Women Liberty with the M100
Prize because we wholeheartedly support their fight for
basic freedoms.
What makes this protest and this
moment so important
if we are honest  We don't yet know
where this movement will lead,
its history continues to be written
as we speak about it here,
but we can already
say with certainty
that something historic is happening in Iran.
For the first time, women in Iran are
both the spark and the
driving force  a revolution
and I bow to the courage of the
Iranian women who lead the protests
before the men,
the courage of the young teenage girls
who burn their veils in the street
is deeply impressive,
they put their young lives at risk
because they want freedom and a
Wishing for a better future
This is not only a turning point for
hundreds of thousands of women and girls in the
country,
it is a deep change in this country
because women are taking the lead,
fighting for their personal freedom
and at the same time for an open and
free Iran
when the Islamic Republic of Iran was
founded in 1979  I was 21 years
old, the same age as Gina when she was killed.
I grew up in Europe
in a society that may
not have been perfect, but I was able to
develop. I was able to demand equal rights as a
woman without fearing state violence.
I am in an open democracy
grew up in which my basic rights
are protected by the rule of law
in the Iranian theocracy
millions of women live in constant fear and
oppression
only a few are allowed to work
they are told how to dress
and behave and that it is
best for them to stay at home
kumini the founder  The Islamic
Republic called the veil the flag
of the revolution.
Now it is the women in Iran who have made
a clear statement in the past year.
They are leading their
own revolution, that of women. They are
fighting to remove the veil of
oppression.
They are fighting for the rights in their
homeland  Iran having a face and a
voice
brings me to my second point.
This moment is also so
important because at the same time these women are fighting for
the fundamental freedoms of all
Iranians.
From the very beginning, it was about more than just
showing off their hair, the sport
To exercise their choice, to be able to work independently,
to love without asking anyone's permission,
these women are demanding freedom from
fear and violence for themselves and all
other citizens of Iran
and that is the reason
why millions of men and women
young and old are protesting  support
and that
frightens the regime to its core
the Iranian theocracy has answered the call
for opening with brutal violence
since September last year the
regime has imprisoned more than 20,000 peaceful
protesters
over 500 have been killed by the
security forces
more than 100 defendants are
now threatened with execution
Dream of a better future that
is the crime that they are
accused of,
but despite all state violence,
the Iranians are
resisting. In July, the trial
against one of the country's most important political
prisoners had to be postponed - the
accused activist Sepider Goljan
had refused to go to court
Wearing a veil
in the city interfered with brave passers-by
when the police wanted to arrest three girls
for violating the dress code.
This shows
that the Women Life Freedom movement
has already changed Iran.
There is no way back.
What can we contribute here in Europe?
have a duty to honor the memory of
Gina and then all the innocent
women and men who were killed by the regime,
I thank you all very much here this evening
for being here for exactly this reason,
but we still have to take action,
we have to hold those accountable
who violate the most basic
human rights
the European Union and its
member states have imposed sanctions against
200 and 4 people and 34 entities
that are responsible for the brutal crackdown
on the peaceful protests
we have
frozen their assets we have
imposed entry bans into the European Union we have all exports  of
technology that can be used to
monitor and oppress
people and
much more.
We will not ease the pressure
until the Iranian regime
ends its violence against peaceful protests, ends arbitrary
arrests, lifts death sentences
and all those wrongfully imprisoned
are released
Human rights must be
respected everywhere, as it says in the
founding document of the United Nations.
Where terrible crimes are committed,
we must have the means to act
because the Iranian regime
not only mistreats its own people,
it also helps Russia
terrorize the people of Ukraine  The
leadership has
decided to
support Russia's war of aggression.
They are supplying Putin with kamikazedons
that will be used for attacks
not only against military targets
but against innocent people. How
Iran relates to Putin's war
must and will have a lasting impact
on the
European Union's artificial relationship with Iran
The struggle and courage of Iranian
women reaches far beyond the country's borders,
it moves and inspires women all over the
world.
The challenges they
face may be different, but
the rights
they strive for are the same.
First of all, the most fundamental of all
rights is the law  Being protected from violence as a woman
Violence against women exists everywhere, including
in Europe. It is never
justified to hit a person.
It is never justified
to hit a woman. It is never
justified to mutilate a girl's body
and no always means
no.
I am proud  that the
European Union has finally joined the convention this year
and for me it is the important task to
bring the first European law to combat violence against women and domestic violence across the finish line this year
because equality
is not coming  Just like that,
progress has to be fought hard for
and is easily lost.
This also applies to countries where there
are no moral police.
Real equality requires daily
attention and commitment.
Women and girls must have the freedom
to pursue both at the same time,
career and family, just as
naturally as boys and men and
women  must be paid at the same level
as their male
colleagues because there is not a single argument
that the same work
is paid differently and women must
of course have equal opportunities
to reach the highest levels because
they have the skills and experience
I believe that a
society in which women
are not only free and equal, it
is a more just society, it is a more
successful society, a
society with much more talent, more
skills and more potential
and I am sure
the violent oppression of women
in Iran will prove to be the Achilles heel of the
Iranian theocracy,
the regime of Iran  women
fail
just as all societies
that marginalize half of their
population lose,
ladies and gentlemen,
in the week after her murder
Marcel Gina Armini actually wanted to
start her studies
Gina wanted to become a doctor
that was her dream to save people's lives
instead she has that  Regime took her life
but they can't kill Gina's dream
the dream of women and girls around the
world to be free and reach their full
potential
there is hope for the future of
Iran because these brave people
set an example every day people the
one  Path for another railway
and I am very happy today that we
have these role models among us.
They will accept the M100 award on behalf of all the
heroes of women live
Liberty
and please join
me in welcoming Schima again,
they have been fighting since
[applause]
China  They have been fighting for
justice, democracy and
women's rights in Iran since 2017. The
regime put them in prison twice.
They were put in solitary confinement.
They were forced to leave their home
but no one managed to
silence them. They are
a role model
for girls  and women all over the
world
and if their father Ibrahim
could see them now
they would be a role model for him too.
The regime in Iran will one day
have to explain what happened to their father,
we will find out the truth and
the culprits will be
held accountable  will
women life freedom
it is a turning point for the women of
Iran
for democracy and freedom in their
country and for women everywhere
they have shown the world that there is
another Iran
and we want to believe in the other Iran
that they stand for we thank
them  for their courage it
is our responsibility to
be loud and clear ourselves in order to give the strong
women in Iran more of a voice.
Thank you for being here today and
the stage belongs to you
[applause] [
applause]
[applause]
[music]
man enjoy  usado had
ring bott phones have
[music]
hamster
[music] [
music] [
music]
[applause]
[music]